[Music]
hi guys I'm Lucy and welcome to reality
check now you might remember on the last
episode I spoke a little bit about how
open-world games like The Witcher 3 are
possible on current gen Hardware like
the PlayStation 4 and Xbox one now if
you don't remember or you didn't catch
the episode be sure to go check it out
because there's a lot of info in there
and it is good I promise I even put in
and that's what she said joke and
everything I promise to cover games
development in greater detail because
when you think about it we take a lot of
things for granted just having games
that can be so complex is really quite
impressive high-end games used to come
on multiple floppy disks whereas today
developers can create vast expanses and
richly detailed lands that can fit on a
single blu-ray or one massive download
after the last episode I dealt headfirst
down the rendered rabbit hole of tech
wizardry and I bumped into none other
than middleware so all right what is
Game middleware well it's a piece of
software that's integrated into a games
engine to handle a very specific task
examples include things like AI visual
effects and visibility and why does it
need to exist well for developers it
saves both time and money why waste
resources creating your own trees or
physics or AI when this pre-made
software that you can pop straight into
your game that way developers can focus
their scarce time and energy on other
aspects of the game sometimes you just
can't see the wood for the procedurally
generated trees that's a nice tree isn't
it oh look at that one now did you ever
think about what goes into making boliya
jenefor estate I'm and effort it would
take for an artist to individually model
thousands of trees would be insane and
would likely turn them insane luckily
there's an app for that or more
precisely middleware called speed tree
no it's not hasty shrub or fast foliage
but speed tree it's a real-time asset
creator that's used to fill games with
lots of lovely believable trees grass
and foliage complete with lighting and
wind effects the tool has a library
containing
roots of tree specimens that developers
can just plunk straight into their game
or they can create their own in a couple
of different ways one way is through
procedural generation create a set of
rules and the software churns out a
number of variants if artists want more
control they can fine-tune their foliage
by changing its appearance level of
detail or even how windswept it looks I
should note that while you can see speed
tree in action in tons of video games it
also crops up quite often on TV and in
movies the same tech that makes the
trees of Far Cry for The Witcher 3 and
of course Tiger Woods PGA Tour 2006 can
also be seen in things like Jurassic
world avatar and Sesame Street it's such
a neat tool that it's even won a
scientific and technical Academy Award
alright alright alright I know it's just
trees but I can never look at them in
the same way again the next piece of
middleware I'm gonna talk about is a
byproduct of streaming which I mentioned
last time to avoid too many loading
screens and to free up memory the game
loads the bit of the world you need into
its memory and dumps the stuff that you
don't but how does the game know what's
visible at any given moment this is
pretty crucial to figure out because in
games like The Witcher 3 or Call of Duty
there's a great level of graphical
detail if resources are wasted on
rendering things that the player can't
even see then the game just won't run
smoothly which is why Helsinki based
Umbra software created a specific piece
of middleware called well Umbra the
technical term for what it does is
occlusion culling basically eliminating
objects that are hidden behind other
objects in the past artists would have
had to limit the player's view or place
occluders which would prevent the
in-game camera from seeing beyond them
but now with modern tech developers
don't have to play such harsh
restrictions on what gamers can and
can't see here's a technical bit Umbra
figures out where the player is standing
then it takes in all of the data of the
surrounding area which is just thousands
upon
thousands of polygons it processes and
condenses them using a process called
voxel ization then runs a visibility
query on the output can the object be
seen or not everything that can be seen
gets spat out in a list and appears in
the game everything else gets cut
therefore saving resources that can be
used elsewhere you can see Umbra in
action in loads of games on current and
last gen the new version number three
can be seen in Killzone Shadowfall
destiny and of course The Witcher 3
where it helps to keep the game's giant
open-world well
giant and of course another really
important thing the middleware can do is
physics and while I don't have the time
to go over all of the available
middleware physics engines in this
episode be sure to check back next time
where I'll be tackling physics havoc and
bullets they all have so much more to
offer than just really cool sounding
names in the meantime you can catch me
on Twitter at Lucy James games I'll see
you next time
[Music]